i want to read you something i want to
read you something because i'm trying to
see more the uh i like the way you
processed everything with real estate
with stocks
you know management teams ceo what could
happen to the market government can
regulate them etc and said okay fine
cash got it if you have 200 million
dollars you know two million dollars you
know 100 000 house in miami now it's a
50 million dollar house okay so maybe
that's also a risk because what florida
would do within 20 years but so here's
what just took place i'm trying to see
for somebody that's uh wanting to play
devil's advocate and be a skeptic
ukrainians
are preparing to lose internet access
okay this is crypto briefing
article per forbes in ukraine apps that
permit basic service like communication
and mapping without internet access are
tapping the downloads charts right now
such applications utilize radio signals
or bluetooth
uh for offline uh functionality and are
common with uh when civil conditions
deteriorate amid war government
crackdown the similar surges on uh such
downloads occurred in 2019 with hong
kong protests right while there has been
an influx of cryptocurrency donations to
the country emmett's its uh invasion
cryptocurrency usage is generally
impossible without internet connection
parts of ukraine's third most populous
city odessa have already lost power and
forbes sources indicated their
expectation that ukraine could lose
power interconnectivity
on a more widespread basis this is where
i'm going with so you know kova takes
place whatever you agree with it there's
a lot of different stories it's a virus
it came from this uh you know lab it
came from this we don't know what market
is a lab we haven't done the
investigation we still don't know the
tribunal courts got to get out there and
say we got to do real investigation
but there was a community that says look
china is known for investing most of
their money in the military bio warfare
that's what their strength is at right
and russia is known for cyber warfare
that's where you know they got the
nuclear weapons we all know they're very
powerful with the nuclear weapons
but
we experienced what
you know if
we had a biowarfare the last 30 months
if we did we experienced a glimpse of it
what it did it shut down the entire
world right what is your concern with a
what a cyber warfare would look like how
would that affect bitcoin and
cryptocurrency
bitcoin is a nuclear hardened protocol
it's it's pretty much the most robust
resilient thing that human race has yet
to invent
for example
it's running uh on on
tens of thousands of nodes you can't
even identify the nodes and there's an
identical copy of the bitcoin ledger on
every one of them
so if all of the electricity got shut
off
everywhere on earth
and every computer failed everywhere on
earth
for 10 years
the protocol just goes dormant for 10
years and as soon as one person turns
one node back on the entire protocol
comes back to life again
there's nothing like that right
all your money in a bank and bank of
america can be wiped out with you know a
keystroke you go and you wipe out a few
servers you know your building can be
wiped out with a bomb right
lots of things can be wiped out but
but um
bitcoin is the most resilient thing in
cyberspace because it is so incredibly
decentralized you know if you took if
you took an entire country offline
that's irrelevant in fact we just saw
last year during the china crackdown
that china banned bitcoin mining
they took 40 to 50 of the entire network
offline half of bitcoin money was taking
place in china the network didn't miss a
beat
not even for a minute it just kept
running completely secure
you could literally wipe out 99
of all the nodes you wouldn't notice in
the network there's nothing else that
you rely upon if
i can take down google and twitter and
facebook and apple and amazon and the us
government and you know there's a lot of
other systems you can take down much
more easily you take down bitcoin
so
i don't really worry about uh about
bitcoin's um fragility to any cyber
attack
in fact the whole point of proof of work
was to create something which is
impervious to a denial of service attack
and it turns out that if you dig a bit
deeper what you realize is that not only
is bitcoin impervious to cyber attacks
it's also the solution to cyber attacks
because
if you want to eliminate denial of
service attacks which are the most
common brute force attacks or you want
to eliminate phishing and scam and spam
attacks and and other sorts of imposters
and malicious behavior in cyber space
the way to do it is to integrate a layer
of
monetary energy which is what bitcoin is
into the internet
you need to wrap
the avatars you need to wrap the people
the websites and the services that we
have in cyberspace with a layer of
digital energy
if you did that you could prevent all
the denial of service attacks you could
shut them down you could probably shut
down most of the scam videos on youtube
all the scamming on twitter all the spam
in your inbox right the simple principle
is
you simply have to post a monetary
security deposit in order to hit my
website or message my inbox or post a
comment and if you're found to be
a scammer or a fisher or a malicious
actor you're fined and we just take your
money
now this is not a problem for an
ordinary person you would post ten
dollars once in your life and you will
trip through cyberspace as you will
but
one thousand times a week someone spends
up a michael saylor bitcoin giveaway on
youtube and those are live youtube class
they'll probably take this interview we
have they'll rip it out they'll put it
into a michael saylor bitcoin giveaway
they'll run it on youtube with 40 000
fake people listening
and they'll have some number where you
can where you can uh send bitcoin to get
send one to get two back
for those people listening i won't get
one scam never send your bitcoin to
someone to get two back you're getting
ripped off so they'll do that and they
will have spun up forty thousand fake
actors
if you actually required someone to post
ten dollars of bitcoin in order to trip
through youtube or use youtube it would
cost you
four hundred thousand dollars every 10
minutes because they get taken down
every 10 minutes and they get spun up
every 15 minutes it's literally
a thousand times a week and so imagine
trying to spend forty thousand or four
hundred thousand dollars a thousand
times a week to do this michael what
type of people fall for those scams i
mean you said you've been a victim of
you'd be using your your name for this
type of
but yeah they obviously work because
they do them every 15 minutes if you
went online right now and type michael
sailor crypto giveaway or something
i just bought a few before i got here so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]